[Music]
meditations is a collection on
leadership and ethics from marcus
aurelius the 16th emperor of rome
next gregory hayes discusses this new
translation it's 50 minutes
good evening everyone and welcome to
barnes and noble booksellers in
charlottesville virginia
my name is michelle alaire and it is a
pleasure to welcome you here for a
discussion and signing of the new
translation of the meditations of marcus
aurelius by gregory hayes
mr hayes translation is the first in 35
years
and it hit the bestseller list in
washington dc in june
an eternal classic of stoicism that
probes what defines justice virtue and a
good life it draws modern readers who
quote in the age of enron are responding
to a leader who takes integrity
seriously says mr hayes
for anyone who struggles to reconcile
the demands of leadership with a concern
for personal integrity and spiritual
well-being the meditations remains as
relevant now as it was two thousand
years ago
gregory hayes is assistant professor of
classics at the university of virginia
he is originally from indianapolis
indiana
received an undergraduate degree from
yale university and a phd from cornell
university
he has published articles and reviews on
various ancient writers
and is currently completing a
translation and critical study of the
early medieval writer folgentius the
mythographer
please join me in giving a warm welcome
to gregory hayes
well let me begin by thanking michelle
for that introduction
and for setting up this event in the
first place and let me also thank our
friends from c-span who are covering the
reading
i think this is very likely marcus
aurelius's first appearance on
television so wherever he is i hope he's
enjoying it
um and thank you also to all of you for
coming out on this very soggy and humid
thursday evening to hear about ancient
philosophy
when we originally set up this event we
talked about it as a reading
but at some point i realized that i
wasn't going to be able to stand up here
and read from a copy of the book in a
conventional sort of way and that's
partly because of the nature of the book
itself
in fact the text that we call the
meditations of marcus aurelius is not
really a book at all
except in a purely physical sense what
it really is is a set of private
scribblings set down over an uncertain
period of time in no particular order
and published at some point after its
author's death we don't know when or by
whom
it was not written with any idea of
publication and in fact it was never
intended to be read by anyone but its
author um i think it's probably safe to
say that no one would have been more
surprised than marcus aurelius himself
to find it enshrined in the modern
library of the world's best books
i'll talk a little bit more about the
nature of the book in a minute but first
of all it might be helpful if i give you
a little bit of background about marcus
himself since he is
not yet a household word
marcus aurelius was the 16th emperor of
rome he reigned from 161 to 180 a.d
and he was the last of a series of
emperors who had come to the throne not
through hereditary succession but
through adoption
we normally call them the antonine
dynasty or the antonine emperors and
most of them are actually pretty boring
characters at least by the standard of
colorful early emperors like caligula or
nero
none of the antonine emperors ever
declared war on the ocean or tried to
make his horse consul
or had sex with close family members at
least as far as we know
for the most part what they did was to
reign peacefully collect taxes receive
embassies build lots of buildings and
die quietly in their beds
edward gibbon famously said of marcus's
predecessor anthony nespios that his
reign was quote marked by the rare
advantage of furnishing very few
materials for history which is indeed
little more than the register of the
crimes follies and misfortunes of
mankind
so marcus enjoyed sort of the opposite
of the famous chinese curse that
everyone is constantly quoting he grew
up in deeply uninteresting times
um he came from an aristocratic family
but not an especially powerful or
important one and in fact i think it's
unlikely that we would ever have heard
of him if he hadn't been adopted at the
age of 16 by the future emperor
antoninus
adoption at this period was actually a
pretty common practice among the roman
aristocracy
this was a period of high mortality a
lot of people died in early adulthood
marcus's own father for example had died
in his 30s when marcus was about 5. so
it was a society with a lot of orphans
and also a lot of older people looking
around for someone to carry on their
family name
as it happens antoninus himself had just
been adopted as his successor by the
emperor hadrian and one of hadrian's
conditions was that antonina should
adopt marcus and another young man named
lucius varus
an heir and a spare if you want to think
of them that way
it's not entirely clear which was which
now antoninus was probably the most
important personal influence on marcus
and this is something that comes out in
the meditations
the opening book of the meditations book
one differs in a number of ways from the
other 11 books it's basically a list of
things that marcus had learned from
other people or qualities that he
admired in them
it starts out with members of his family
his grandmother his mother and so on and
then his teachers and mentors and winds
up finally with the gods
the second to last entry is devoted to
antoninus um and it's also the longest
entry it's even longer than the entry
for the gods
and i'll read it in full um not only
because it's the best description of
antoninus that we have but also because
it helps us to get a sense of marcus
himself
of the qualities that he valued in a
leader and presumably the ones that he
tried to embody as an emperor
i should note incidentally that any of
you who already own copies of the book
will have noticed on the back that
random house has classified it as
spirituality slash business um
i think that they were hoping to get a
cut of the leadership market
um
so this is my my my nod to that that
marketing strategy
all right meditations 116 my adopted
father
compassion
unwavering adherence to decisions once
he'd reached them
indifference to superficial honors hard
work
persistence
listening to anyone who could contribute
to the public good
his dog a determination to treat people
as they deserved
a sense of when to push and when to back
off
putting a stop to the pursuit of boys
his altruism
not expecting his friends to keep him
entertained at dinner or to travel with
him unless they wanted to
and anyone who had to stay behind to
take care of something always found him
the same when he returned
his searching questions at meetings a
kind of single-mindedness almost never
content with first impressions or
breaking off the discussion prematurely
his constancy to friends
never getting fed up with them or
playing favorites
self-reliance always
and cheerfulness
and his advanced planning
well in advance and his discreet
attention to even minor things
his restrictions on acclamations
and all attempts to flatter him
his constant devotion to the empire's
needs
his stewardship of the treasury
his willingness to take responsibility
and blame for both
his attitude to the gods
no superstitiousness
and his attitude to men no demagoguery
no carrying favor no pandering
always sober always steady
and never vulgar or prey to fads
the way he handled the material comforts
that fortune had supplied him in such
abundance without arrogance without
apology
if they were there he took advantage of
them if not he didn't miss them
no one ever called him glib or shameless
or pedantic they saw him for what he was
a man tested by life accomplished
unswayed by flattery qualified to govern
both himself and them
his respect for people who practiced
philosophy at least those who were
sincere about it but without denigrating
the others
or listening to them
his ability to feel at ease with people
and put them at their ease without being
pushy
his willingness to take care of himself
not a hypochondriac or obsessed with his
appearance but not ignoring things
either
with the result that he hardly ever
needed medical attention or drugs or any
sort of sav or ointment
this in particular his willingness to
yield the floor to experts in oratory
law psychology whatever
and to support them energetically so
each of them could fulfill his potential
that he respected tradition without
needing to constantly congratulate
himself for safeguarding our traditional
values
i often think that modern leaders could
learn something at least for marcus
not prone to go off on tangents or
pulled in all directions but sticking
with the same old places and the same
old things
the way he could have one of his
migraines and then go right back to what
he was doing fresh and at the top of his
game
that he had so few secrets
only state secrets in fact and not all
that many of those
take that john ashcroft
the way he kept public actions within
reasonable bounds
games building projects distributions of
money and so on
because he looked to what needed doing
and not the credit to be gained from
doing it
no bathing at strange hours no
self-indulgent building projects no
concern for food or the cut and color of
his clothes or having attractive slaves
the robe from his farm at lorium most of
the things at lenuvium
the way he accepted the customs agent's
apology at tusculum
we don't know what any of these events
refer to i should add it's one of the
minor mysteries of the meditations
he never exhibited rudeness lost control
of himself or turned violent no one ever
saw him sweat
everything was to be approached
logically and with due consideration in
a calm and orderly fashion but
decisively and with no loose ends
he could have said of him as they say of
socrates that he knew how to enjoy and
abstain from things that most people
find it hard to abstain from and all too
easy to enjoy
strength perseverance self-control in
both areas
the mark of a soul and readiness
indomitable
as i say i think you learn from that not
only a great deal about antoninus but
also about marcus himself
um antoninitus in any case died in 161
and marcus dooley became a co-emperor
with his adoptive brother varus
as we've seen the early and mid 2nd
century were a period of calm relatively
speaking for the roman empire but it
turned out to be the calm before the
storm and it was really during marcus's
own reign that the clouds started
gathering to begin with there was a war
with persia which varys had to go off
and fight while marcus stayed in rome
the war itself went reasonably well the
romans more or less won on points but
when they came back it turned out that
the troops had brought disease with them
we're not sure what disease it was
exactly but it was clearly a major
epidemic that killed thousands of people
and took several years to run its course
when that was done marcus and varus
found that they had to deal with
everybody's favorite menace the
barbarians
in this case barbarians from central
europe what today is hungary and romania
any of you who have seen gladiator will
remember that nightmare garish battle
scene at the beginning of the movie with
romans hacking at barbarians and
barbarians hacking at romans and richard
harris as marcus aurelius looking as if
he'd blow away if you breathe too hard
that in any case was what marcus spent
most of his later reign doing and his
last decade in particular seems to have
been a pretty dark one his colleague
varus pre-deceased him his wife died one
of his trusted governors revolted in
syria
his son commodus may not have been quite
as slimy as the joaquin phoenix version
and gladiator
but he was certainly no marcus aurelius
a lesser man might have turned to drink
marcus turned to philosophy
this is not altogether surprising he had
studied philosophy as a young man all
educated romans did but he seems to have
been more committed to it than most and
it was certainly what sustained him in
later life
for this to really make sense though you
need to understand something about the
role of philosophy in the roman world
for us philosophy is an academic
discipline
in some ways a kind of marginal one
i hope that there's nobody from the uva
philosophy department here tonight good
um
marginal i think partly because of the
way that it's been conducted at least in
in britain and america for the last
hundred years
modern philosophers have by and large
sidestepped the big metaphysical
questions the ones that most of us take
to be fairly central to our lives like
why are we here and what happens to us
after we die
we've come to regard those questions
somehow as the province of religion
rather than philosophy
that's not how things worked in the
ancient world ancient religion had very
little
to our way of thinking surprisingly
little in the way of an ethical
component
ancient religion was primarily about
sacrificing cows
if you wanted to know the meaning of
life you didn't go to a priest you went
to a philosopher
now at this point the importance of
philosophy as a basis for spiritual life
is something that's been especially
stressed in recent years by the french
scholar pierre ado
who back in 1992 wrote a very good book
on marcus aurelius called the inner
citadel
and it's ado who i think explains best
what marcus was up to in writing the
meditations which probably date from
that troubled last decade of his reign
the meditations is not a diary in the
conventional sense it contains almost
nothing about marcus's own external life
but neither is it a philosophical
treatise exactly it doesn't have a
continuous argument it wasn't written
for publication as we've seen
and from a philosophical point of view
it's not even particularly original
what it is is what ado calls a set of
spiritual exercises
the meditations quite literally is a
self-help book it's a book that marcus
wrote to help himself
another way of looking at it is that
it's what we would now regard as
cognitive therapy
now the philosophy that marcus practiced
was a philosophy called stoicism and i
should perhaps talk a little bit about
that
stoicism has roots in earlier greek
philosophy but the two people mainly
responsible for systematizing it are two
third century bc thinkers called zeno
and chrysippus
zeno used to lecture in a covered arcade
in downtown athens the greek word for an
arcade is a stoa
and that's where the label stoic comes
from
stoicism started out as a greek
philosophy and a rather abstract
academic philosophy in some ways but in
the first century bc it was discovered
and taken over by the roman aristocracy
who found it very compatible with their
own value system
in fact it's been said with some justice
that stoicism was the roman
aristocracy's real religion
stoicism in its original form was a
comprehensive system it set out to
explain everything about the way the
world and the universe worked and it's
based on a particular physical
conception of how the universe is
organized
the other great philosophical system at
this period stoicism's main rival a
philosophy called epicureanism argued
that the world was completely random
that it was just a meaningless
conglomeration of atoms
stoicism goes to the other extreme it
sees the world as highly organized and
the organizing principle is something
that stoics called logos
now logos is one of those untranslatable
concepts that all languages have but
that greek is perhaps especially rich in
the basic meaning of logos is rational
thought either the capacity to think
rationally or the coherent expression of
rational thought namely connected human
speech
all human beings have logos
in fact that's what defines us as human
beings that we have a share in that we
participate in or partake in the
universal logos because the individual
logos that each of us has is part of a
higher all embracing logos
the rational power that governs the way
the universe works
logos in that larger sense often is
synonymous with what we call providence
or nature with a capital n
or even god
in some ways it's not unlike the quaker
concept of the inner light something
that everybody has inside them but which
is also
out there and pervading all things
but the stoic logos is not just an
abstract concept or an impersonal power
it's also an actual physical substance
like oxygen or carbon
the stoics believed that the world was
pervaded physically by logos which they
imagined as an intangible fiery sort of
material which constitutes the life
force in humans and in all living things
dylan thomas is forced that through the
green fuse drives the flower is the
logos when we breathe our last breath
logos is what we breathe out
now obviously this poses certain
problems for a translator
you have here a concept that is so
central to marcus's philosophy but that
it's almost impossible to find a single
english equivalent for
most previous translators have rendered
logos as reason which is not wrong
exactly but i think makes marcus sound
too much like an 18th century
rationalist or perhaps like mr spock and
star trek
demanding that everything be logical
in the end i decided that the only
reasonable adequate rendering of logos
was logos and if english-speaking
readers can handle karma and the dao
well then they can probably handle logos
as well
and in fact when marcus talks about the
logos he often sounds quite a bit like
lao tzu
meditations 10 12.
to follow the logos in all things is to
be relaxed and energetic joyful and
serious at once
meditation six five
the logos knows where it stands and what
it has to do
and what it has to work with as you can
see it has sort of mystical overtones at
some points
now the world that we live in is
governed and directed by the logos which
means that it's a rational and organized
world although not necessarily always in
ways that are clear to us
we're like the threads in the tapestry
we're too small to see the overall
design but our lives contribute to it
and so does everything else that happens
meditations 440.
the world is a living being one nature
one soul keep that in mind
and how everything feeds into that
single experience moves with a single
motion
and how everything helps produce
everything else spun and woven together
meditations 10-5
whatever happens to you has been waiting
to happen since the beginning of time
the twining strands of fate wove both of
them together your own existence and the
things that happen to you
now this web of fate or design woven by
the logos is what marcus refers to as
nature
and the goal of the stoic is to live in
accordance with nature or to do as
nature requires
in other words we have to be ready to
play our part in the play that the logos
has created this is an image that marcus
uses a number of times the idea that we
all have walk-on parts in this vast
cosmic drama
of which the logos is the playwright in
which we have to play to the best of our
ability
so how do you go about living in
accordance with nature
well you do it by mastering what pierre
ado has identified as the three
disciplines
this triad of ideas that is really very
central to marcus's philosophy into what
goes on in the meditations
the first of these is the discipline of
action we have to
pay attention to what use we make of our
own logos how we control and direct our
efforts as members of society
and that mention of society is very
important because for marcus aurelius as
for most other ancient thinkers
human beings are above all things social
animals whose purpose in life is to
interact productively with others
meditations 9 23
you participate in a society by your
existence
then participate in life through your
actions
all your actions
any action not directed toward a social
end directly or indirectly is a
disturbance to your life an obstacle to
wholeness a source of dissension
meditations eight twelve
when you have trouble getting out of bed
in the morning remember that your
defining characteristic
what defines a human being is to work
with others
i have to say i don't myself find this
especially helpful when i'm having
trouble getting out of bed in the
morning but um that just goes to show
that i'm not a very good stoic
meditations 12 20
to undertake nothing at random or
without a purpose
or for any reason but the common good
now all of this sounds easy enough when
marcus aurelius tells himself and us to
do it but of course in the process we
often encounter obstacles circumstances
other people that prevent us from
carrying out our praiseworthy ambition
and we have to learn to deal with those
obstacles
meditations 4-1
our inward power when it obeys nature
reacts to events by accommodating itself
to what it faces to what is possible
it needs no specific material
it pursues its own aims as circumstances
allow
it turns obstacles into fuel
as a fire overwhelms what would have
quenched a lamp
what's thrown on top of the
conflagration is absorbed consumed by it
and makes it burn still higher
meditations 5 20.
when people obstruct our proper tasks
they become irrelevant to us like sun
wind animals
our actions may be impeded by them but
there can be no impeding our intentions
or our disposition
because we can accommodate and adapt
the mind adapts and converts to its own
purposes the obstacle to our acting
the impediment to action advances action
what stands in the way becomes the way
now this brings us to the second
discipline the discipline of the will or
what marcus quoting an earlier
philosopher epictetus calls the art of
acquiescence
and this is sort of the flip side of the
discipline of action the discipline of
action deals with what we do ourselves
the discipline of the will deals with
what is done to us by other people by
impersonal forces
by the world and above all by fate
because for the stoic remember
everything that happens is part of the
plan there are no random events
which means that we are not free agents
as individuals except in a very very
limited sense
for the stoic free will means that we
have the freedom to align our own will
with that of the logos
the stoics have a useful image for this
which is that we are like
dogs or a dog which is tethered to a
wagon
which is rolling along the highway
and the dog can either trot along behind
the wagon accepting its movement
or he can be dragged
fate is ultimately going to do what it
wants but the best thing that we can do
is to accept it and even to welcome it
whatever it is exactly that it sends us
meditations 12 11
the freedom to do only what god wants
and accept only what god sends us
meditation 6 9
everything is brought about by nature
not by anything beyond it or within it
or apart from it
meditation 757
to love only what happens what was
destined
no greater harmony
now of course sometimes that's hard to
do as well what happens can sometimes
seem very unpleasant not at all
harmonious and very hard to love
here if we're good stoics we need to
exercise the third of the three
disciplines the discipline of perception
for the stoic it's not what happens to
us that's the problem it's how we
interpret it
so it's important to look
dispassionately at what happens and to
separate the facts from inappropriate
judgments about them
if my house burns down for example well
that's a fact
i have to accept it as such what i don't
have to do is say to myself my house has
burned down i've suffered a terrible
misfortune this is a catastrophe my life
is ruined
these are false perceptions um something
that i'm imposing on that basic fact and
i don't have to do that i can choose not
to
when i do that i'm exercising the
discipline of perception
meditations 849
nothing but what you get from first
impressions
that someone has insulted you for
instance that
but not that it's done you any harm
the fact that my son is sick that i can
see
but that he might die no
stick with first impressions don't
extrapolate
meditation 641
you take things you don't control and
define them as good or bad
and so of course when the bad things
happen or the good ones don't you blame
the gods and feel hatred for the people
responsible or those who decide to make
responsible
much of our bad behavior stems from
trying to apply those criteria if we
limited good and bad to our own actions
we'd have no call to challenge god or to
treat other people as our enemies
meditations 5 19
things have no hold on the soul
they have no access to it cannot move or
direct it
it is moved and directed by itself alone
it takes the things before it
and interprets them as it sees fit
so those are our three goals to direct
our actions properly to accept what we
don't control what happens to us
and to see things clearly and
dispassionately
in fact if you wanted a quick summary of
the meditations you could do a lot worse
than the so-called serenity prayer grant
me the serenity to accept the things i
can't change the courage to change the
things i can and the wisdom to know the
difference those are marcus's three
disciplines right there will action and
perception
now if we apply these disciplines
properly the end result is that we
should achieve a kind of internal
balance or self-sufficiency
meditations 449
to be like the rock that the waves keep
crashing over
it stands unmoved and the raging of the
sea falls still around it
meditations 8 48
remember that when it withdraws into
itself and finds contentment there
the mind is invulnerable
it does nothing against its will even if
its resistance is irrational
and if its judgment is deliberate and
grounded in logic
the mind without passions is a fortress
no place is more secure
once we take refuge there we are safe
forever
not to see this as ignorance
to see it and not seek safety there
means misery
meditations 11 12
the soul as a sphere in equilibrium
not grasping at things beyond it or
retreating inward
not fragmenting outward not sinking back
on itself
but ablaze with light and looking at the
truth
without and
within so this is the stoic's goal
but of course it's not one that most
people even most stoics achieve without
effort certainly it's not one that
marcus found easy to achieve and i think
that's one of the things that people
have most often responded to in the
meditations over the centuries it's
clear that marcus found the practice of
this philosophy very difficult and
frustrating and that comes through in
what he writes
i've called the meditations a self-help
book and it is i think in some sense
that but it's that very rare thing a
self-help book that doesn't talk down to
you
partly of course because he's not
talking to us at all
marcus is not a purveyor of timeless
wisdom despite what you may read on the
the dust jacket
he is not pushing 12 easy steps to a new
stoic you
um he is not showing the seven habits of
highly effective roman emperors
sometimes he's angry sometimes he's
depressed like most of us he's a work in
progress and i think it's that inner
drama that makes the meditations as
effective and moving as it can be
sometimes
as you read through the meditations you
get a sense of the things that marcus
wrestled with most often the problems
that recur
over and over in various entries
the distractions of court life worries
about what other people thought of him
frustration with his subordinates the
fear of death
the hardest lesson for him is for a lot
of us is to keep things in perspective
and one of the exercises that he seems
to have found most helpful was to step
back and look at the big picture
meditations 10 27
to bear in mind constantly that all of
this has happened before
and will happen again
all the plots the identical sets
produce them in your mind as you know
them from memory or from your reading
the court of hadrian of antoninus
the courts of philip alexander crisis
all just the same
only the people different
meditations 432
the age of vespasian for example
people doing the exact same things
marrying raising children getting sick
dying waging war throwing parties doing
business farming flattering boasting
distrusting plotting hoping that others
will die complaining about their own
lives falling in love putting away money
seeking high office and power
and that life they led is nowhere to be
found
or the age of trajan
the exact same things
and that life too
gone it's a little depressing perhaps
but it's also kind of calming
to take another self-help axiom marcus
tells us not to sweat the small stuff
and in the larger perspective of the
logos of course it's all very small
stuff indeed that sense of the smallness
and the transience of things is
something that really stands out in the
meditations
it's something i think that marcus has
in common with certain strains of
buddhism
closer to home it's something that's
very characteristic of a lot of ancient
literature in particular homer's iliad
and virgil's aeneid
meditations 5 23
keep in mind how fast things pass by and
are gone
those that are now and those to come
existence flows past us like a river the
what is in constant flux the why has a
thousand variations
nothing is the same or even close to the
same
the infinity of past and future gapes
before us
a chasm whose depths we cannot see
so it would take an idiot to feel
self-importance or distress
or any indignation either
as if the things that irritate us lasted
meditations 443
time is a river
a violent current of events glimpsed
once and already carried past us and
another follows and is gone
i'll close with a few of the shorter
entries which i think are often the most
effective and powerful
this is something that i think marcus
learned from the early greek philosopher
heraclitus who was of course the guy who
said that you can't step twice into the
same river and that the road up and down
are the same
sometimes less is more
to accept it without arrogance
to let it go with indifference
many lumps of incense on the same altar
one crumbles now one later
but it makes no difference
the best revenge is not to be like that
a rock thrown in the air
it loses nothing by coming down
gained nothing by going up
it was for the best
so nature had no choice but to do it
the cucumber is bitter then throw it out
there are brambles in the path
then go around them
to stop talking about what the good man
is like
and just b1
thank you
as michelle mentioned i'll be happy to
take questions um and just a reminder
that if you can speak up so that the
c-span people can can hear you
would you say a little more about
things that
were
questions for you or problems for you as
translator you mentioned this in terms
of
the choice of the logos can you say
something of other kinds of things that
you had to wrestle with
um
it took a little bit of time to to find
an idiom that seemed to work
i mean this is not a you know whatever
genre the meditations is exactly it's
not really anything that that we're used
to to writing in
and
so it took some time to figure out
you know to find a voice for him in
english
one of the problems that that i kept
encountering was that
our moral vocabulary in english has i
think progressively over the last couple
of generations been
cheapened
to the point that when you have somebody
like marcus or aurelius telling you um
you know be virtuous practice justice
it's hard to translate that with a
straight face it just sounds silly to us
so that was that was kind of a problem
i had to to get that across without
making him sound
you know arch or flip
or just dumb
greg did he himself use the word logos
in
well the meditations i'm glad you raised
that point actually the meditations are
in fact written in greek
um most people are surprised to hear
this but it actually makes a certain
amount of sense in the the context of
ancient philosophy um the romans always
had a kind of cultural inferiority
complex vis-a-vis the greeks and greek
was really the language of culture
of philosophy of medicine of the higher
sciences
and um
you know that's perhaps
you know that that very problem that you
mentioned is is perhaps one reason why
marcus wrote in greek rather than in
latin and that a lot of the the key
terms that he you know that were part of
his philosophical system um really had
no good latin equivalence
and it simply came more naturally in
greek
talked in latin at home but written
all his meditations and i mean he would
have used latin for his administrative
decrees
right um i mean most most romans um
starting in
you know the the first century bc were
functionally bilingual um
i mean he would have been just about as
comfortable in greek as in as in latin
the greeks on the other hand never
learned latin it was beneath them
frankie tell us about the source
material for your translation
um yeah the
i mean the very early history of the
meditations is something that
i for one would like to know a good deal
more about
i mean what
what exactly marcus wrote on what form
he wrote in we don't know
probably papyrus scrolls perhaps wax
tablets
something like that
as i say we don't know
who collected these things and put them
together and edited them how much
editing they did
when they were
first started to circulate
around the 4th century we start seeing
references to them in other authors so
it's clear that they had been
been published by then but the first
couple of centuries are kind of kind of
a blank
beyond that
like all ancient texts they were copied
and recopied
by generations of of scribes
and um the meditations is actually one
of those texts that very nearly didn't
survive
it drops out of sight for hundreds of
years at a time we hear you know a brief
mention of it at one point in the 9th
century it pops up again in the 12th
century
and
[Music]
the
it's one of those cases where
the first printed edition
is actually
the
best source for the text of of the
meditations it was obviously based on um
a handwritten manuscript which hasn't
survived
but
it's a very very tenuous kind of of thin
line that has brought the meditations to
us
um and as a result there are a lot of
places in the text where it's very
difficult to figure out um what's going
on there are clearly copyists errors um
you know entries that have gotten
squished together or that need to be
separated
it's a very messy text to try and make
sense of in some places i mean i've
tried to indicate that at points in the
translation where there's real doubt
about about what marcus is saying that
printed text that was in latin
no it was in greek
first book he quotes from female family
members is that uncommon
um
not so much in a roman context
um i mean there were a lot of of um
fairly dynamic upper class roman women
running around and i don't i don't find
it at all surprising that some of
marcus's family members were were in
that category um
i mean in general the family members get
much less play than than people later on
teachers and mentors and so forth um
mostly for you know grandfather
grandmother mother it's just sort of one
or two lines
um
but the women are certainly there
given the earlier philosophy that dealt
so much with the civic aspect this seems
like almost a a retreat or a
disengagement from that
is that how you would take it
um
i don't think so i think it it appears
that way to some extent because it's
marcus talking to himself dealing with
his own problems
um if he'd been writing for a wider
audience i think he probably would have
said more about
you know the way that people should
behave in society
how society should be should be
structured perhaps
those sorts of things but this is really
a sort of private talking to oneself
and i think that's
that's what's responsible for the kind
of
um
almost self-absorption that that one
feels sometimes
how do you think 21st century america
would i mean reacts to a philosophy like
this and in a related question who
besides john ashcroft is getting a
complimentary a copy of your book
um well to answer your last question
first um you know our previous president
has cited the meditations as
his favorite book and one that he
rereads every few years i haven't
actually sent him a copy perhaps i
should
[Music]
in terms of of how 21st century
americans would respond to it i don't
know i suppose they would respond to it
in different ways
i think that that there are a lot of
things
in the meditations that
[Music]
that people would find very sympathetic
today as they have it you know for the
past few centuries
um
a lot of the things that people seem to
be concerned about today achieving inner
serenity um handling stress those sorts
of things are problems that marcus is
facing
there are other aspects of of the
meditations that i think we probably
find it harder to access
i mean scientific knowledge has
obviously moved on since the stoics
you know there are certain aspects of
stoicism as a comprehensive philosophy
that nobody could accept today
um
so it's you know like most ancient
literature it's a mixed bag
um but i think that that
that's one of the things that that
drives us to read ancient literature is
to ask you know what here is familiar
what here is novel or strange to us
and to compare back and forth
did you run into any suggestion that
this manuscript was preserved and
protected by the early christians
um i think that's unlikely um i mean
marcus himself
was the titular head of a government
that was
suppressing christians often rather
violently
there are one or two cases in the
meditations where
people have suspected that there might
be a kind of covert reference to the
christians
i'm inclined myself to think not at
least in most cases i think the the
christians for marcus aurelius were
this you know small troublesome sect
um
who you know had to be dealt with
when they got out of hand and he had
officials to do that
i mean it's i think there's a good deal
in the meditations that is not
incompatible with
ancient christianity or many many modern
forms of it
but
you know marcus really certainly was not
a a crypto christian and i doubt that
most early christians would have found
him a very sympathetic figure he was for
them in many ways the enemy
does that
well i'm just thinking of the emperor
constantine and
they would probably have had access
to these manuscripts however they were
written
could they have been responsible for
protecting them
would they have seen these meditations
as a
philosophy related to their own beliefs
well by they you mean
the early christians under the emperor
um
[Music]
anything is possible
i mean the the early history of this
text is just so
blank to us
that you know i'm reluctant to say no
that couldn't have happened
it doesn't seem to me as likely as that
it was um
you know kept by
marcus aurelius's immediate successors
um you know a secretary even his son
commodus
could have tidied it up and put it into
circulation
but you know this is all guesswork
do we have the public voice of marcus
aurelius against which you could play
off
this private meditative voice well we do
to some extent i mean we have um
you know various
legal decisions and um you know letters
issued by marcus aurelius or in his name
in response to to embassies and appeals
and what have you um
it's kind of hard to draw a direct
connection there simply because
so much of marcus aurelius's public
voice may not really be marcus aurelius
at all it may be you know the
undersecretary for whatever um
responding to this particular petition
from the people of ephesus or what have
you
um
so it's it's hard to
to really compare the two i think
claire
i'm wondering about your experience as a
translator
and i have um two questions
related to that i wonder how you came to
translate this book and second if in the
process of translating
it became a way of meditative practice
for you and this comes from
the readings that i'm doing in buddhism
and as you mentioned
um the real connection
that once that i heard between the
buddhist thoughts and the the meditation
so i wonder and buddhism being very
anchored in the practice of everyday
life how you end it don't talk about
being a good man just be it
i wonder if
translating the daily practice it became
a certain practice where he was
addressed
okay um
to answer your first question
um i came to translate the meditations
almost by accident um will murphy my
editor at random house um emailed me out
of the blue one day and and said um do
you want to do you want to translate
something for us um and i said sure
maybe
and um we batted a few ideas around and
um i would say you know what about
roswitha the well-known medieval nun who
wrote latin dramas and he said great
sounds like a terrific idea how about
marcus aurelius
and i would say what about philosophus's
life of apollonius and he would say wow
terrific how about marcus aurelius
and
after a while that became began to seem
the thing to do um
and it was it was an interesting project
for me because it's a little earlier
than most of my own scholarly work
and i'm really a latinist rather than
somebody who works on the greek side so
it was a chance for me to to explore
some new territory or at least sort of
new territory
and that was very enjoyable
um
as far as integrating marcus aurelius
into my own meditative practices um
i suppose it was meditative in a sort of
way i mean i did most of the translating
in various coffee shops around
charlottesville um
with you know a text of marcus aurelius
on the table on a stack of index cards
and so forth
it was
i mean it was certainly something that i
enjoyed translating and something that
was very helpful to me at that stage i
had been coming out of a bad bout of
depression
and the meditations um
you know is very helpful
in that kind of situation it's a very
calming
kind of work it makes you feel more
serene and more accepting about life
um and that i think was was a good thing
i'm certainly grateful to have to have
had that chance
no other questions
can you say a little bit about how this
translation differs for
differs from or is continuous with
previous translations
um sure the um
i mean the history of translating marcus
aurelius is is much richer in some ways
than a lot of other ancient texts it's
never been a text that that professional
classicists have been very interested in
are very exciting excited about um i
think because it's not
you know at all autobiographical
if we had you know marcus aurelius's
diary where he says you know woke up at
9am executed some christians went out
and had lunch whatever um that would be
really interesting um
so it's it's a text that that you know
is no good to social historians because
it's all about philosophy um it's also
not really a lot of use to students of
ancient philosophy because it's
you know fairly derivative in in purely
philosophical terms um you know marcus
aurelius wasn't
writing original philosophical thought
nor was he setting out to do that
um on the other hand it's always had a a
great appeal to
to non-classicist to the you know the
famous common reader
and so there have been a lot of of
english translations although curiously
none for for 30 or 35 years
in terms of what i was trying to do with
the translation
a lot of the earlier translations i
think make marcus aurelius sound much
more
formal
and much more um
almost king jamesy in some sense um than
i think the the greek text itself really
is um i mean you've got the sense that
this is marcus aurelius the great sage
um
you know offering you timeless wisdom to
guide your life by and i think that's
not really what the meditations is
so i was looking for a more
sort of straightforward
almost colloquial tone in some parts
that would really
make the translation
you know accessible to to people in the
21st century
okay well let me thank you all again for
for joining me on this occasion
thank you very much
thank you so
[Applause]
i'd like to invite much
up to speak further with greg and get a
signed copy of the meditations thank you
all for coming
meditations of marcus aurelius is
published by modern library a division
of random house
visit randomhouse.com
modern library for more information
[Music]